a man who won a landmark lawsuit against
the agriculture giant Monsanto is
speaking out for the first time only on
CBS this morning
Monsanto was ordered to pay 289 million
dollars in damages to former school
groundskeeper Dwayne Johnson the jury
found the company widely used glyphosate
based weed killer was a substantial
factor in causing Johnson's rare cancer
is the first of thousands of similar
lawsuits that the company faces across
the u.s. in a war nurse spoke with
Johnson and a good morning good morning
Nora he's the man who went up against
Monsanto and won but Dwayne Johnson who
goes by Lee says his lawsuit started
with a desire to warn others about the
potential dangers of chemicals that
glyphosate based weed killers he says
caused his terminal cancer to put it
bluntly you're dying yes but you say
it's not about you know ya dyin is
something that everybody has to do
alright so if you know you're dying it
gives you that extra push it's like okay
well you can't just die for nothing
y'all they don't know I am an integrated
pest management / grouseman Lee
Johnson's ordeal began when he took a
job as a Pest Control Manager for a Bay
Area School District starting in 2012
part of his job spraying glyphosate
based weed killers made by monsanto
chemicals he says trainers told him were
safe one of the things stuck out to me
the worst is that when they tell me it
was safe enough to Jane safe enough to
drink safe enough to drink that's that
was really absolutely it became the joke
almost like a Manitou drink it it was
like what you know it was really a shot
despite that Johnson says he always wore
his protective gear while spraying some
20 to 30 times a year sometimes two to
five hours a day are you gonna get it on
you you're gonna get it on your skin you
know the man there was never like oh I
didn't even get any on me today it was
always like man I'm glad I had this off
especially he says after a hose came
loose spraying chemicals inside his suit
it was a few months after that he
developed a rash that spread over his
body they never went away and he got
worse and worse and where
doctors diagnosed him with non-hodgkin
lymphoma cancer later that year he
called Monsanto what did you want to ask
them what I wanted to ask them you know
is it possible that maybe if someone got
this on their skin would they get sick
but they did rashes what they did
lymphoma and what did they say to you
you know she definitely said mr. Johnson
somebody will give you a call about this
it won't be me but somebody will call
you and will talk to you about did they
ever call you back no an email
introduced at trial shows an executive
was notified and wrote that he would
call Johnson back in a later deposition
the executive said he didn't recall
whether he'd ever spoken to Johnson so a
little over a year later in 2016 with
his health declining Johnson sued
earlier this month after an eight week
trial in nearly three days of
deliberations the jury stunned the world
with a 289 million dollar verdict
against Monsanto finding the company
failed to warn Johnson and other
consumers of the cancer risks what did
that verdict mean to you the verdict
really meant to me that this thing was
not done in vain and I remember standing
there saying to myself if I lose this
case this company is going to be able to
get away and they'll be able to say see
I told you our stuff didn't do that
Monsanto still says its products did not
cause Johnson's cancer after the verdict
executive vice president Scott partridge
said we all have tremendous sympathy for
mr. Johnson and his and his family what
they've gone through with his disease is
is terrible but of the verdict he said
it doesn't change the overwhelming
scientific evidence and the forty years
of safe use of glyphosate around the
world what do you make of the fact that
Monsanto is not backing down they have
to not back down is what I think you
know what I mean it's like if they just
say come out and say okay well okay you
got us that's the end of them
Monsanto promises to appeal Johnson may
not live to see the fine
outcome of his lawsuit but he says
knowing the end is near has allowed him
to pass on the lessons of his life to
his two sons I want my son's to know to
go forth and always do what they're
supposed to do and never be weak and be
strong all the way through but you gotta
have pain oh yeah the pain makes you
stronger
things like that happen but I think it
happens for a reason I'm still here I
was supposed to be going a long time ago
it's hard times always kind of up and
downs all these kinds of you deal with
that accordingly you move forward
Monsanto continues to say that 800
scientific studies and reviews including
a conclusion from the Environmental
Protection Agency support the fact that
glyphosate does not cause cancer but
Johnson hopes this verdict will lead to
labeling changes for these products so
he says more people will know the
potential risks and be able to choose
whether they want to use those products
he seems like a very humble man you know
you know it's amazing yeah to have that
outlook and he as he says move forward
and not feel down and depressed all the
time yeah he says he does get down but
he's got his family there and these sons
have a lot to be proud of in there does
he's had time to talk to his sons
because he knows the ends coming and it
could be very soon yeah it's important
that we're hearing from him Anna thank
you